I just told you dr. Manhattan is here
and Tulsa walking amongst us as a human
being and you never asked me who he is
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my watchman episode 7 video
they just blew the doors wide open holy
crap
dr. Manhattan has been walking amongst
us this whole time so we'll break it
down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and they've been seating along
Clues this whole time so some of you may
have guessed the twist so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos in careful for
spoilers from the episode obviously
because we'll be talking about some very
big twists top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
starting with number 10 the episode
opens with a documentary about dr.
Manhattan's life his origin story both
sides of the aisle people that loved him
and worshiped him as a God people that
hated him and thought that he made
things worse the title of the episode
was an almost religious awe which i
think is a reference to the awe that
people feel when they think about dr.
Manhattan there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs for present day when they do
that documentary they explain why
there's no gasoline cars anymore
Manhattan powered lithium engines all
this technology derived from him
basically he becomes this big
pop-culture icon is like a Marvel
superhero one of the Avengers like
Robert Downey jr. is Iron Man or one of
the DC heroes but we see the very first
footage of him in the actual series
itself when they show clips from Vietnam
now they did that sequence during the
Watchmen movies so you kind of
remembered that but the way they air
this footage it's as if it's a
documentary that was filmed back during
Vietnam era and is being played back in
present day on a videotape because it's
all happening within the context of
Angela's flashback to Vietnam when she
was a little girl about ten years old
number nine they tell Angela's origin
story we get the origin of the sister
night vigilante name that she took the
sister night blaxploitation movie that
she was never allowed to watch they say
it's too scary I guess we could say that
it's implied that she eventually watched
it like even her grandma's like oh that
was a great one what do you mean you
haven't watched it yet oh do they say
that I'm not allowed to watch it they
used the flashbacks to get across a
whole bunch of exposition about what
happened to the world after dr.
Manhattan came to Vietnam and help them
win that war they also use it to connect
to Angela's flashbacks on the nostalgia
to her grandfather's memories because
you see her father as an adult here but
you also flashback to him as a little
kid learning that his father was
secretly hooded justice they explained
her parents were killed in a terrorist
bombing and she went to live in a group
home
for a number of years until her
grandmother came to try and bring her
home we'll talk about that in a second
too because that little girl cannot
catch a break
lady true starts to explain the
nostalgia trip she gives her to this
really funny tutorial Injection it's
like a chemical version of memories
trying to talk her out of the trip that
she's on the interesting Easter Egg
during this that you probably spotted is
the Cyclops filed that her grandfather
compiled when they're telling her to
meditate and think about something while
this is doing its job I feel like they
explained most of what they needed to
explain about Cyclops through the course
of this episode if you weren't clear on
what was going on at last week's episode
they definitely explained it this week
but you learned that Lauri is still on
her side she's the one that's centered a
lady true because lady true is the
person that manufactured the de staël
juh drug in the first place later in the
episode too when she's talking about the
Millennium clock on this broadcast
that's being played back she talks about
how nostalgia was one of her greatest
failures I feel like nostalgia could
have been this really great tool for
people to learn from the past and then
use it to move forward but that's not
what happened the whole speech about
nostalgia is the writers doing this meta
commentary about the dangers of
nostalgia wanting things to go back to
the way they used to be preventing
people from moving forward in evolving
so Lady trues big millennium clock
probably has something to do with that
I'll talk about that in a second - she
refused to tell Angela exactly what the
Millennium Clock does but I think they
gave us enough clues because of what's
going on with the nostalgia drugs but
number 8 Laurie versus the Chiefs wife
so she goes to visit the Chiefs Widow
they have this pleasant conversation she
tells through this mind-blowing story
about Cyclops and this grand conspiracy
that her husband may have been part of
and they play it in the most hilarious
way possible where the wife just
completely comes clean oh well you know
that was initially the plan but then we
felt like making Senator Kean was small
potatoes and that gets into the larger
plan about them becoming dr. Manhattan
after they kill him when she was saying
small potatoes I'll explain that in a
second that's a whole other thing this
big secret plot of the seventh cavalry
to take the powers of dr. Manhattan I
love the joke about the trapdoor the
fact that it's just so old that she has
to mash the button a bunch of times to
get it to work number seven we get the
flashback where Angela decides she wants
to be a cop someday so she's asked to
identify the person that helped kill her
parents which she correctly does she
says that she's not
afraid she actually wants to listen to
them execute the person the lady cop is
nice and like no you can't do that
but when you ready come visit me you
would make a good cop someday gives her
her badge they're using this to let you
know how hardcore she was as a little
girl otherwise she wouldn't have been
able to survive on her own for that long
but number six WTF lady true drops the
bomb about her daughter oh she's not my
daughter she's my mother I cloned her
and took her memories and I'm slowly
reintegrating them into her I'm getting
ready to achieve my greatest
accomplishment and I want my parents
there with me oh are you gonna bring
your father back to oh he's not here yet
she kind of buried the lead on bringing
her father back so I'm wondering if uh
Sandman deists or one of the other old
Watchmen characters is gonna wind up
being her father but number five
Ozymandias is trial as of this scene
it's been going on for the last 365 days
we also got clarification on his
timeline - he's been on a different
timeline than what's been happening in
present day so the present-day stuff in
Oklahoma moves day to day week to week
but every time we visited Ozymandias
it's actually been a year between
episodes so it's just a year later when
we pick up with him in this episode they
play it like it's gonna be really
serious but he's basically being judged
by all these other clones they talk
about how he's made a mockery of the
trial this whole time told everyone how
he's so far above them then the game
warden also plays a bit of a joke on
Ozymandias sliding him by bringing in
all the pigs a jury of your peers as
they all come squealing in he's guilty
it's hard to tell where they're going
with this because it seems like
Ozymandias is just waiting to be rescued
so he's just trying to wait these people
out he is powerful enough to defeat them
in hand-to-hand combat so at least it
looks like he just feels like he has to
wait this out like he doesn't think he's
in any kind of danger from any of them
but number four lady Tru explains her
plan to save the world
without completely explaining how the
millenium clock works what is it going
to set off is a giant dome shape it's
constructed in the most defensible
safest place on earth that's why it has
to be Oklahoma also probably has
something to do with dr. Manhattan being
in Oklahoma but because of the scene
right before this where she's on that
recording talking about the dangers of
nostalgia and how people just completely
misused it and had trouble moving
forward and evolving as a species and it
sounds like it has something to do with
wiping everyone's minds and creating a
new
start point for the beginning of the
next era of human evolution like in an
earlier episode they refer to the clock
as the eighth wonder of the world and
she says no I like to think of it as the
first wonder of the new world
so maybe the clock will wipe everyone's
minds creating the stage for this new
world but number three laurie is
captured by the seventh Cavalry she
wakes up at that same abandoned mall
base that Looking Glass was taken to
where senator Keene showed him the truth
about what happened during the original
Watchmen series in Ozymandias his plan I
love the back and forth the fact that
she has been through a lot of this stuff
before in the original Watchmen series
she just doesn't care like whatever your
plan is I just don't care about it but
the big twist is is that they plan on
capturing dr. Manhattan somehow and then
killing him in taking his power that's
what the cage is for that they're
constructing there was also talk in an
earlier episode about the Russians
secret plan to create their own version
of dr. Manhattan he would be called dr.
Moscow but through a couple different
characters they basically explained that
the 7th cavalry want to take his powers
so that they can become gods and do
whatever they want number two is the
reveal that lady true knows who dr.
Manhattan is and has been using this as
part of her millenium clock plan with
Angela's grandfather this whole time
even though she sounds like she's
getting really short with Angela because
she knows that Angela knows who dr.
Manhattan is and just isn't saying like
Angela in this moment here might seem
like she doesn't know but very clearly
she knows because she goes home and then
releases dr. Manhattan so lady true was
just getting a little pissed off with
Angela like are we gonna keep pretending
here are we gonna be honest with each
other you're secretly hiding dr.
Manhattan at your house I feel like the
big elephant WTF was meant to be a
reference to the elephant in the room
saying the elephant in the room in a
meta way being that she's secretly been
hiding dr. Manhattan this whole time so
the fact that she busts in and sees this
giant elephant is just the writers
winking at that idea but because she's
been working with Angela's grandfather
it sounds like she wants to help protect
dr. Manhattan and he's also critical for
her plan in activating the millenium
clock but number one the final dr.
Manhattan reveal because of the way they
edited the episode when they went from
lady true then directly to her husband
reading for Whom the Bell Tolls by
Ernest Hemingway I feel like most people
had made the connection oh it's clearly
going to be him he's door
manehattan who's just changed the color
of his skin and created this fake body
for himself so that he can walk around
and pass as human most of you are
probably more confused about why he can
look like this when dr. Manhattan
clearly looks like this based on the
original series like he was born a white
man he was a physicist how come he looks
like Black Manta from the Aquaman movie
her grandfather actually gave us all the
clues that we needed at the beginning of
the series he said dr. Manhattan can
change the color of his skin he can make
himself look like whatever he wants it's
a critical piece of technology though
was that device that she pulled out of
the hole in his skull that was
suppressing his powers most of you are
asking why he would make himself look
like this though and that probably has
something to do with camouflaging
himself from the world because everyone
knows what dr. Manhattan really looked
like when he was a human so if he just
turned himself back into his normal
human form people would never leave him
alone and clearly from the teaser in
next week's episode because of the way
his mind works he just goes from one
woman to the next like you see him go
from his original wife to Silk Spectre
to during the ritual Watchmen series
very clearly the same thing happened in
Vietnam he fell in love with a new woman
and that just happened to be Angela in
in order for them to be able to be
together he had to find a way to make
people think that he was not dr.
Manhattan thus the disguise the biggest
question for me right now is actually
how the Ozymandias plot is going to
connect to the dr. Manhattan plot and
present-day
because dr. Manhattan is the person that
put him there that's happening in the
past very quickly by the finale that
will catch up with present-day
but if he's rescued and then brought
back to earth what is he going to do
then there's the question of what
happens to the 7th cavalry because I
don't think that any of us believe that
they will actually become gods and be
successful in taking the powers of dr.
Manhattan so everyone post your theories
in the comments below if you have any
big questions I'll try to add it to my
video next week there's only two more
episodes while you wait for everything
click here for my brand-new baby Yoda
mandalorian video and click here for all
my other watchmen videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight